and the reds will get a second look
at brad keller in a week brad keller has
pitched 11 innings he is not allowed to
run he has been on top of his game joey
vada will dig in to get this thing
started
and he gets a strikeout after falling
behind three-and-oh keller goes to work
against nick castellanos and a
slider is swung on it missed caspian is
fooled by that pitch swinging right over
the tops of the color
he starts things with back-to-back
strikeouts jesse winker coming up winker
19 hits batting average three six five
with that winker takes outside ball four
and remember that at bat started 0-2 and
that'll bring a eugenio suarez to the
plate on the ground to monday he'll go
the short way and they get the force on
winker elise castillo gets the ball for
the red legs today and for castillo he's
making his fifth start of the season and
it's his second consecutive start
against the royals he faces whitmerfield
to galveston short
and
missed by votto whoa that's a nice break
early there went merrifield to board and
now it's the royal second baseman nikki
lopez weekly bounce the right side glove
by the second baseman van meter flips
tovato for the out but on the play
merrifield's gonna move up 90 feet the
hitter is hunter dozier
and that is outside for a walk on a
close pitch and the royals have two on
with one out and a couple of gift bases
from the reds for two on one out for
schiller and solaire hammers it to left
field so how's that for a start to the
home stand he has an rbi double and the
royals turn that air into a run second
and third and the royals are still at
work as ryan o'hearn climbs into the box
brian o'hearn hits it into right center
field and that's going to be down
here comes dozier with solaire right
behind him and ryan o'hearn gives the
royals a three-nothing lead in the first
inning now he's in scoring position and
it'll bring up alex gordon swing and a
miss and castillo climbed the ladder
against gordon he went after it he's
down on strike
and i'm sure it's
somewhat
disappointing for mustaches to return to
kansas city without fans in the stands
to
greet him with a warm applause
but
it's the first time that he's played
against his former team the organization
that he grew up in
became a star and
he has continued to flourish
in the air to left field and
alex is into the corner that ball
carried on him a bit lopez is out on the
fly to center for the second out of this
second inning and that'll bring hunter
dozer to the plate strike three called
change up at the knees locked him up and
dozier is down on strike brad keller
has set down six of the first seven
split with the twins and now are going
against the reds today there's a swing
and a miss on a very good slider and
brad keller gets his fourth strikeout
and cincinnati's still looking for its
first hit of this game against brad
keller will be castianos to lead it off
now the 1-2 and he hits this one high in
the air deep to center field merrifield
back at the wall he's there for the
catch
well we're fortunate
and it's a long way to center field and
with that big scoreboard center
the ball just doesn't carry here's the
pitch high fastball and winker works his
way back winker has walked for a second
time that'll bring up a eugenio suarez
popped up right side lopez moving over
towards first base will make the catch
and everybody stays put two out and that
brings up mike mustakas keller's first
pitch swung on pole to o'hern he grabs
it touches first base that will do it
keller keeps the work going he has now
gone 15 innings in 2020 and still has
yet to allow a run the reds are going to
bring the infield in
opens up the field for win he loves the
situation here and on the ground a
second and monday was coming down on
contact and it may have distracted van
meter it gets by him and the royals lead
four nothing in the fourth and keller
for his part has four scoreless innings
in their center fielder their japanese
import akiyama leads off swinging a miss
he got him a pitch down the slider
that's really been biting today and he
has his fifth strikeout there's a
bouncer back to the mound off the glove
of keller picks it up fires to first and
o'hern has to reach into foul territory
to make the catch but he keeps his foot
on the bag five innings of no hit
baseball for the kansas city righty brad
keller the reds got to figure out a way
to get the bats cranked up but they got
to break through with their first hit
before they can think about dinning the
plate tucker barnhart will lead things
off of the reds 301 pitch barnhart
swings and lines one to center field
that'll fall for a base hit
right in front of mere field and the
reds have their first hit of the
afternoon and it comes leading off the
sixth inning the no hitter win five
innings
now it's up to the former royal mike
moustakis to try to extend this game
lines this one into right center field
that will fall for a base hit in front
of mere field and mustache
is a board with a two out single never
say never
the pitch akiyama
lines this one to right field that's a
base hit and now two on with two out and
the tying run suddenly moves into the on
deck circle but trevor rosenthal will be
summoned from the royals bullpen brad
keller's day is done
one out shy of a complete game pitching
change made in the seventh with two on
and two out it'll bring josh van meter
to the plate and he does get it done
very quickly so he is six for six and
save opportunities
and rosenthal and brad keller combined
on a three-hit shutout